congratulations are in order for a Jenna
Dewan and Steve Kazee who are officially
engaged the couple who was already
planning for their little one on the way
announced the big news Tuesday evening
with the heartwarming Instagram post
they both shared this romantic photo
Jenna captioning get quote a lifetime to
love and grow with you you have my heart
Steve writing quote when you wake up in
the morning I will kiss your face with
the smile no one has ever seen the
flirty dancing host started publicly
dating the actor in 2018 and opened up
to ET and December about why he is the
guy for her kind of that unspoken
chemistry you just know if you have it
it's the sparks that fly and yeah it
just works really well their engagement
comes just a few months after the pair
announced they are expecting their first
child together it's mind blowing the
whole thing watching a child grow inside
of a human has been like the most
amazing experience so far Jenna who was
already the mother to six-year-old
Everly whom she shares with ex-husband
Channing Tatum shared with ET how her
little girl is feeling about becoming a
big sis she's really excited she's
really protective it's been cute she's
worried about what I'm eating making
sure it's healthy she when I say mommy
means to sit down and take a break she's
like totally gets it she hugs and
cuddles the belly I mean it's really
been adorable you never know how it's
gonna go and so far she's been so
excited she tells the entire world every
one every way even just people that
check us out at stores she's like did
you know my mom's right
there like we can see
[Music]